liberty weekend is finally here and
events are heating up all across the
valley as summer begins to come to a
close good evening and thank you so much
for joining us tonight at 11 o'clock i'm
sasha loftis a brand new music festival
kicked off tonight but there were some
covert related requirements for fans to
get in orco mana is live at the downtown
las vegas events center to explain hey
there orco
well sasha this is the lost in dreams
music festival and let me tell you it's
quite a party out here this started a
little bit earlier tonight you can hear
those dance beats and see the flashing
lights but in order to get in on all the
action here at the downtown las vegas
event center attendees had to show
either proof of vaccination or a
negative covid test
fans flocked to the first ever lost in
dreams music festival and one of the
things i've been looking forward to
wearing their best festival gear
attendees witnessed unique sights and
sounds saturday night at the downtown
las vegas event center organizers say
the three-stage event put on by
insomniac delivers an immersive
experience like no other but before
enjoying the dubstep and dance tracks
everyone had to show proof that they've
gotten their first vaccine dose or a
negative covet test you would have to
show your card organizers in blue shirts
checking for the documentation at the
gates attendees tell us they're willing
to do whatever it takes to enjoy the
festival i think that it's really
important that we all like take these
precautions and necessary precautions
and
you know if everybody is on the same
boat then we can have event more events
like these in the future most people
agree it's a simple step to take to feel
more protected it is a big event and you
know we want we all want to be safe and
we all want everyone to be healthy so
i'm totally fine with it i've been
vaccinated so i mean um
you know the safer the better you know
that that's what i say
while the festival feels like a little
sense of normalcy has returned we're not
out of the woods yet we're still
technically in a pandemic so we have to
make sure that
you know
everybody's safe